bugs is a good look - did you have a
rough J Pejic fury I'm gonna need
clarification on this space invasion
scrolls are infiltrating your planet are
shapeshifters
[Music]
okay prove you're not scroll as a photon
blast and I'll scroll can I'll do that
I'm just supposed to take your word
today
we are crate strong United
remember my controller
I have this power
but I don't know where it came from I've
never seen anything like her you think
you can find us she's just the beginning
you've come a long way leaner strong as
you think
what is this logo announcing your
identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job said the space
soldier was wearing a rubber suit
tickets now hey everybody its charlie we
got a whole bunch of new Captain Marvel
footage to break down we're doing a new
round of that imax ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment on the video the big thing about
this is just in filling out a little bit
more of the back and forth the actual
feel for what her character is like when
she's not delivering those big
one-liners like she's actually talking
Nick Fury they're cracking a couple of
jokes with each other
they started out with the Terminator 2
reference with her going to the biker
bar in the leather biker jacket the Nine
Inch Nails Nick Fury makes fun of her
for being super 90s grunge while the 90s
song comes on the record player in the
jukebox and she just blasts it to hell
squirrels can't do that it's a photon
blast they polished a lot of the special
effects in this but you get a little bit
more of her explaining the actual Secret
Invasion of it all if you don't remember
avengers Secret Invasion from the comics
that's basically what they're doing for
this movie which is why I don't think
that they'll do another bigger version
of Secret Invasion in the future of
enters movie like they'll always be
Scrolls in the future movies but they're
not gonna riff quite as hard on The
Secret Invasion aspect because they've
started finishing some of the effects
you actually see the scrolls change into
other people when they spot that really
hot chick with a surfboard on the beach
even the train fight with her looks a
little more polished and they have a
couple of different angles like you see
her grab the back of her head and jam it
into the pole there look at this dude's
face in the background - he's horrified
like oh my god what's happening to this
old lady they have way more funny
reaction shots like right after she goes
to town on this little old lady's scroll
she blows the hair out of her face
really casually then is a sort of
commentary on not being able to tell
whether or not people are really scrolls
just saying you'll have to trust me and
sort of laughing at him a little bit
cocking her eye up like maybe I am a
scroll but yeah pretty sure in this
moment she's not a scroll mostly because
a lot of you will recognize when she
said Scrolls can't do that when she
gives off her photon blast that only the
super scroll can emulate other people's
powers regular Scrolls can just do their
appearance I'm sure they'll test the
limit of that during this like how hard
do you have to hit them before they
start to change back love the look on
Sam Jackson's face while he's just
soaking it all in like you just can
barely believe it
you're picking up a lethal weapon or
like 48-hours vibe that's because the
director sort of built that buddy-cop
aspect into the film like they're
riffing on a lot of those big 90s
buddy-cop
action films Terminator 2 is a big one
die hard is a really good example Sam
Jackson was in die hard three his Nick
Fury haircut even looks like the haircut
that he had during die hard three
speaking of which other big Terminator 2
reference the jacket she actually gets
from Rob Kazinsky if you don't recognize
him here
he seems like he's supposed to be some
funny tough biker dude that tries to
come up on her maybe hit on her and she
just completely lays him out steals his
jacket like Schwarzenegger taking the
clothes of the bikers at the biker bar
and their bike and then taking off so
it's like saying that she's the
Terminator during this movie I don't
know if they're actually gonna give
anyone that line come with me if you
want to live or any of shorts and acres
lines from that movie because it does
feel like they're going for some of
those comedic beats you get a whole
bunch more of the Kree homeworld and her
with Star Force this actually looks like
it's from early in the movie like well
you see them flying through space and
what looks like a little bit of water
here - with their masks up because the
kree-skrull war is such a big part of
the movie this just seems like a random
mission to go take down some Scrolls
it's not really clear when they find out
that the scrolls have targeted earth and
then head back this fight that she's
happening with Jude Law's character who
we now know is actually Yan rock is
actually very telling like he seems like
he's trying to help her control her
abilities but he says leave the past
behind you she keeps talking about not
remembering where she's from I don't
remember anything about my past and then
she gets a little bit of a temper after
he puts her down she starts to light her
fist up control it calm down this seems
like very clear set up for a big fight
between the two of them by the end of
the movie like they have this lesson
that he imparts to her some sort of
brutal wisdom then at the end of the
movie when she's remembered her past and
become this fully actualized comic book
version of Captain Marvel completely
binary she turns whatever wisdom he's
laying on her back on him while she's
beating the crap out of him love the
extra shots of her getting her powers in
the explosion from the psyche magnetron
infusing her with energy the way brie
Larson and Kevin Feige talk about it is
is the accident only unlocks or enhances
things that are already there so I do
think that you know she's bleeding that
green blood the
she is going to be part Cree during the
movie but there been a couple prequel
stories where they changed her backstory
from the classic version of Carol
Danvers
so we'll see there'll be a couple things
that'll be a little bit different from
the comics I'll talk about that whenever
I do Easter Egg videos there's the funny
Avengers reference from Nick Fury when
he's talking to his boss
Talos who he does not know is secretly a
scroll in disguise you think you'll find
more like her talking about finding
other super-powered people oh she's only
the beginning and you know even though
technically Captain America is the first
Avenger obviously after this in the
early mid-2000s is when we start seeing
the Hulk manifest we start seeing Iron
Man we get that post-credit scene where
he tells him about the Avengers
initiative so this movie is also going
to serve as sort of the birth of that
idea that eventually evolves into the
Avengers initiative but I don't know if
he'll actually coin that phrase during
this because we're heading into Avengers
endgame it just feels like a really big
teaser moment like haha he's doing the
thing like there'll be a little file
folder that will read Avengers
initiative on it as he closes a drawer
or something like that
the only other stuff about this other
footage that's different is that
everything from like the end of the
trailer where she's gone full binary and
she's flying around blowing all those
Crees ships up is that they polished the
CG a lot better so everything looks a
little bit sharper the colors pop more
you can pick her out of the background a
lot better like this is full mohawk shot
just looks way better than the previous
ones that we've seen so far I do love
the way she lights her hair up when she
activates her powers and the explainer
for why she has the Mohawk it's just
really the way the helmet forms around
her head so that all of her long hair
just sticks out the top and that's where
the Mohawk comes from her talking about
photon is also a reference to the
character photon Maria and Monica
Rambeau so Maria Rambo is Monica Rambo's
mother Maria was one of her friends in
the Air Force she was another pilot her
code name is Photon and when she grows
up her daughter Monica Rambeau gets
powers she calls herself photon for a
little while but I believe she's calling
herself spectrum right now in the comics
so I do think that we will see some
version of a young Monica Rambeau just
implying that maybe someday she'll grow
up and become one of these New Avengers
level characters but no idea they're
gonna try and pay that off during
avengers endgame or if they'll save that
for another Captain Marvel sequel
because
zooom ibly when the next Captain Marvel
movie picks up if there is a sequel
it'll be during present day so it'll be
20 years after the events that are
happening right now there's also an
Avengers reference at the end when Nick
Fury is burning her for wearing the
rubber suit when she makes fun of
wearing your logo on a hat like
announcing yourself whenever you go this
sort of a larger joke about people like
spider-man or Captain America that wear
their logo on their chest like you sort
of announce who you are the minute you
walk in like you know exactly who
spider-man is when he walks into a room
like oh you have a spider symbol on your
chest if you guys didn't see it either
there was a big Kevin Feige interview
where he was talking about everything he
talked a lot about Captain Marvel he
talked about guardians of the galaxy 3
about Avengers endgame I will do a
separate video about that there were a
lot of people that were confused and
seeing all kinds of rumors about Hugh
Jackman Wolverine and Avengers endgame I
do think it's kind of ridiculous but I
did make a video addressing that so I'll
post that sometime in the next day or
two for those of you asking about New
Avengers endgame trailers and footage
I'm not expecting that till we get to
the Super Bowl because every year for
the last couple of years they bought a
Super Bowl ad at least one so we'll at
least see some Avengers endgame we might
also see some more Captain Marvel but
we'll see because there's only a couple
weeks away if you spotted any big Easter
eggs that I didn't mention in the video
just leave them below in the comments if
you have any specific requests for bonus
videos don't worry there's a couple
Marvel videos that I'll be posting in
the next day or two while you wait for
everything click here for that new Game
of Thrones season 8 teaser and click
here to learn why Marvel just retconned
Loki and Thor in the MCU before endgame
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]